20:19 is coming to an end but before we
say goodbye we want to take a look back
at all the platforms see how they're
doing we've done Xbox we've done
PlayStation we've done switch now we're
on to PC Michael what would you say some
highs and lows are for PC now surface
level only we'll get into the weeds in a
bit all right
there's some good exclusives man you see
that every year with PCs that there
there's innovation in this certain type
of genres at PC excels at we got that
this year a new hardware came out as
well whether it's VR or new video cards
that came out didn't like bus down any
doors or anything but it kind of sets
the stage for what's to come in the
future so PC had a decent year yeah Ben
what about you highs lows uh just having
all whole bunch of games coming out
we've got all the different platforms
now with like the epic game store
they've been throwing a whole bunch of
really good games at us for free I've
been building up a library there and
it's really impressive just be able to
play all my favorite games in my
favorite place I guess yeah I mean you
mentioned epics story I think that's
probably a good place to start now
there's been pretty divisive I'd say
among the gaming community a lot of
people aren't too wild about epic store
because they've been doing a lot of
exclusives timed exclusives a lot of
people want all their games on Steam and
epic kind of threw a wrench in this and
what's even more interesting we're gonna
do it later but GOG then kind of
followed that up with a new client that
shows games from every single platform
whether that be I think even
Playstations shows up no you can't
launch your PlayStation games you can at
least like look at it and be like I've
got blood-borne
yeah the this year has been for PC it's
been a year of gaming storefronts and
gaming services like we mention epic
game store I mean it launched late last
year in a fairly primitive state you
know we didn't have things like cloud
saves which are sort of expected with
that and they've kind of improved on it
over it's still lagging behind the shirt
but yeah they're getting there right
yeah I mean steam has been out for so
long so of course the steam is gonna be
at the top of its game but competition
is necessary I mean you if you don't
like epic game store you have to at
least give credit to it for you know
instilling some competition because you
can't have steam
steamrolling the PC distribution market
and dad because up until this year I'd
say they were I think most people would
agree that steam kind of has the
monopoly here but now gog has made a
pretty good pretty strong case for
itself and so has uh uh has those epic
game store yeah and there's a free like
you've been you mentioned epics giving
out free games and they're good games
like they're not I wouldn't be ones I'd
leave there to like wait till the next
one pops up I'm grabbing them almost
constantly even like if they're games I
have on Steam already but they're
they're worthwhile yeah and the
exclusives who are big because these
aren't just like smaller games you we
add Metro Exodus yeah metrics is control
was another big warm Borderlands three
or Alliance three yeah there's another
recent one too right and it's it's not
things just like epic games to its X
Xbox game pass on PC that's more of a
service type thing but it's another way
to get games on PC and it really great
way like I I'm a big fan of Xbox game
pass and I don't even have an Xbox so
play everything on PC but I subscribed
to game pass for PC and I got I got to
play at outer worlds gears v the Forza
games and the smaller games like
creature and the well I also play
through a game pass it's you know PC
storefronts and PC game services are
changing man and it's it's nice to see
yeah that was a weird realization for me
when I was like I have outer worlds on
game pass but I kind of want to play it
on PC and then and then someone told me
like oh you can play it on PC knows like
I can yep
and it's it's cool because I prefer
playing things on my PC and I subscribe
to game pass so it's kind of nice that I
have that option to just hop on over to
PC if I want and normally that's what I
do want to do yep
Michael you touched on innovation a
little bit and I would say one of the
big innovations this year is that
there's a new genre on PC which doesn't
happen super often but the auto battler
John genre what can you tell us about
that let me tell you about auto battlers
it was born out of a dota 2 mod called
Auto chess and it was it's this weird
game setup where it has like a drafting
model kind of like MOBAs and then you
set up your units in strategic ways with
different unit synergies and you just
let them battle so it's more about
planning and then letting it go and it's
it's just a different way of playing a
strategy type of game because MOBAs came
out of RTS and now Auto Valor is coming
out of MOBAs and word the big names dota
is doing it with dota under Lords
yeah don't under Lord so that's a valves
thing then you have teamfight tactics
which is from riot we're using League of
Legends stuff and then there's also
hearthstone it just announced and also
put out our sown battlegrounds and you
see these big MOBA companies coming out
with their own auto battlers and who
knows where it goes from here but you
can't deny that 2019 there's you spawn a
new genre and like I mentioned it's it's
that innovation that you see on PC and
this is also like I said it came out of
a mod yeah and that's kind of the trend
with PC new genres typically right like
even last year two years ago when people
were all crazy about battle right yeah
that came out of a mod that was on PC
and it wasn't until I'd say last year's
when it hit really hard on consoles yeah
and same thing with Auto battlers that
that came out of a mod and look where it
is now mm-hmm and then I think the next
big thing to talk about for PC is
exclusives
what were some of the exclusives that
stood out to you guys we've got a got a
kickoff with disco Elysium man yes
that's definitely I think my personal
game of the year so far but I it is it's
a C RPG at it at its core but it does
more than that as well but that is a big
standout for me and I think many people
on PC I think that's a game that a lot
of people will be gravitating towards
hopefully yeah they should there will be
console versions in the future but again
this originated on PC and it's very much
a PC style game and it does a lot for
what RPGs can be because it's not
there's no combat system there's a lot
of reading but the way in which they
contextualize your choices and also
incorporate dialogue and the writing is
absolutely stellar it's it's a very
special game yeah I really appreciate
the writing especially it gives me like
a kind of a good grim fandago feeling
which prepending is one of my favorite
games of all time
kind of really silly and kind of pokes
fun in itself even like your dialogue
options will what kind of force you one
way and have like weird commentary and
them that you wouldn't expect in like a
dialogue system and it's there
throughout all of it and just the idea
that all of its kind of sitting around
like your mind arguing with itself kind
of also really gets me yeah this is a
good time yeah it's like I said there's
no combat system but there's still a lot
of conflict and it just it's a creative
way to kind of have this force push
think pushing against you yeah based
around your choices in what you have
access to I mean everything you say
pretty much there is a back and forth
between the skills you invest in those
become voices in your head and you're
second-guessing every decision you make
because a voice is telling you no that's
stupid why would you ever say that or or
you should tell them this and then
you'll tell them that and he'll get mad
and you're it's really it's really
interesting how it does that and it's
something that hasn't really been done
before at least in that genre yeah it's
an impressive how many things that game
accounts for mmm-hmm whatever choices
you make will affect the other and it's
just this sprawling web of different
things that you can do and a fascinating
story that is you know you can you can
play again and again and still find new
story threads throughout depending on
what what you speck into and the choices
that you make a dialogue so very special
game I'd say it was also pretty big year
for mmo's though before we get into
Final Fantasy 14 Wow classic is also a
pretty big deal right yeah yeah it it's
was kind of a really interesting thing
we finally gave us what we'd been asking
for for a long time a way to play the
original World of Warcraft the way that
it was more difficult enemies are
everywhere and then you just forever to
level up yeah it takes forever to level
up it's it's a it's interesting thing
and I I know personally I appreciate
that it's there but also while playing
through it I got to maybe like level 30
or 40 again and I was like okay this is
this is cool I remember it and I kind of
didn't want to play it too much anymore
which is kind of a weird thing but I
also kind of was thinking forward in the
head too
what are they gonna do with this once
you're at the max level and you've
cleared all the content are they gonna
eventually give us access to like other
expansions or whatever but I there's no
place for me to go so I just kind of
stopped after I realized that and then
you started boot anything you booted up
Oh
Final Fantasy 14 was a constant
throughout the whole but I I went right
back to the Final Fantasy 14 and had
been I literally was playing it a little
bit before and it was a huge year for
Final Fantasy 13 right huge year if the
new expansion shadow bringers changed a
lot in that game or it made it even
better I think that we all know the
story about Final Fantasy 14 how 1.0 was
was killed because it wasn't a great
game relaunched had an incredible
expansion pack with heavensward and then
had another great expansion pack its
storm blood but something is very
special about shadow bringers in the way
that it kind of tells a much more grand
story and recontextualizes so much stuff
that has been in the game's lore for so
many years on top of being such a great
game with incredible music dialog and
powerful moments that it's people talk
about how final phase 14 is a great
tells a great story for an MMO and I
think that's selling it's short and it's
it's a great story period and it's a
it's a wild accomplishment that Square
Enix not only overcame its kind of
shortcomings as an MMO like what you can
do with an MMO story-wise
has overcome those limitations and has
used those to its advantages and if you
make it to the end of shadow brainers
granted you have to go through a lot of
content to get there or have been a long
time player it is so rewarding and on
top of the 5.1 update which then brought
yeah new raid Nier automata bronze
overcomes and stuff yup absolutely
exciting year for Final Fantasy 14 and I
have been to thanked for for getting me
on that train I'm happy to help
I'm glad I'm just happy you're here and
you're having a good time
yeah that game is also on ps4 but I mean
it being an MMO it's very much a PC
based game yeah I think most people when
they're thinking of
fantasy 14 it is PC PC is is is kind of
feels like its home more or less I'd say
sure yeah but but speaking of that -
there was some other big I mean it'd be
impossible to go through all the PC
exclusives but some other big standouts
were more tau which I know been you had
a chance to play some of that it's it
was kind of cool to see kind of like the
idea of what chivalry had kind of done
bringing multiplayer melee fate like
focused combat and they improved it and
made it feel a lot more seamless and
they put kind of the silly stuff in
there you can play like a bard with a
lute and beat up a person with a sword
with a lute don't play music you're
charging into battle and someone's
playing like a 1 M 1 at dooms gate like
as you're charging in it's it's it's a
really fun game that I actually should
probably go back to again I kind of fell
off of it a bit because just everything
else started happening but it's it's
really fun and I'm sure they're
continually updating it and putting more
things into it but it's it's a great
feeling melee combat multiplayer game on
your PC and I don't think it's coming on
anything else so yeah and then I guess
to wrap up big exclusives for PC
Nintendo may have had three houses but
PC has three kingdoms we're talking
total war three kingdoms that game was
reviewed very well a very deep strategy
game I don't know if either of you had
much of a chance to play that eyebolt
I'm aware of the Total War franchise I
didn't get hands-on with three kingdoms
but I do recognize how much it has
changed or and and also what it what it
embodies for Total War again something
that you only see on PC and kind of
taking like ancient Chinese history
incorporating that into its a its story
and by all accounts like its story lines
came out very well but also expanded on
the Forex strategy mechanics that you
expect from games like this so I don't
think we could talk about PC without
talking about VR I'd say I think you
mentioned earlier that it feels like
this year they're setting up for bigger
things to come with VR but we still had
some things like the oculus quest is a
big one the the valve index and whatnot
like it was it was a pretty big year for
VR
Michael you've tested out most of these
headsets sure have yeah and each one
offers their own kind of unique thing
Quest is a standalone product though you
don't necessarily need a gift not really
PC but it's kind of Jason yeah and also
because of quest the was it the PC link
for oculus quest and if you're not aware
you can actually buy a very long cable
to hook directly up to your PC and then
kind of get those PC based experiences
because quests again like I said
standalone Hardware so it's kind of
limited in terms of what you can play on
it but now if you connect a cable to it
you are now enabling essentially what
you can access on a rift and there was a
new rift model that came out this year
to the rift s is and both of these
headsets have inside out tracking so you
no longer need to think about your VR
gaming space in terms of where am I
going to set up these sensors now it's
built into the headset and that is a
great innovation for VR and I think that
makes it a lot easier as a prospect for
someone who might be interested in to be
yeah I mean I think that is a that is a
big selling point for a lot of people
myself included like I was not really on
the VR trained eye in dedup getting a
quest just because I didn't feel like I
was gonna be tethered to a room that has
sensors set up with a cord connected to
my PC and like a bunch of USB cables
hanging off such an important aspect
right but it is it is exciting to see
them expand and open up VR and different
ways which could the timing is great
right because we've got half life Alex
on the way which is a killer app if I've
ever seen one right that games coming to
2020 but man the the news of a new
half-life game I think that's important
for 2019 is a big 2019 story man it's
been so long 12 years and will be
thirteen years by time this game comes
out since we saw a half-life 2 episode 2
and this being a VR game you know maybe
you'd be disappointed that it's a VR
game but I think that this is very much
in line with what half-life is known to
do which is pushing the boundaries for
games think about half-life 1 and how it
pushed first person shooting narrative
games and then half-life 2 which was a
great game in a physics showcase now
half-life Alex looks like another
physics showcase but in terms of what
you
can do in interacting with your
environment VR this is all based on the
trailer but if that all comes to
fruition and half live Alex so that is a
huge step forward for VR and to wrap
wrap the valve index into the discussion
is that finger tracking you can only get
on the index controllers and the game is
probably looks like it's going to
account for finger tracking a lot more
than what I've seen so far on index yeah
it's actually really interesting to see
how that announcement has actually
driven up index sales at least on Steam
it's been on top sellers list for a bit
now wild and I never thought I'd see
that just because of the price that it's
at but in selling it yeah the index is a
very expensive investment but it is the
most advanced to be our platform yet
yeah and valve waited to bring out the
big guns for that huh yeah I guess I
can't believe them well anyway that's PC
and 2019 thank you all for watching and
make sure to stay tuned because we have
more report cards just like this on
GameSpot right now and on December 17th
we're going to reveal our game of the
year so make sure to stay tuned for that
see y'all
[Music]